how are you doing good I want to start
by saying congratulations on the show
the first two episodes were so well done
um I guess I have to start with with
Stephen when I asked you about the first
question which is you're a very y-you
are very in demand actor I've seen I
mean just some such great work recently
what was it about this the scripts in
this material that said I want to you
know make another series I it was the
best writing that I'd seen in a long
time
film or otherwise and I as soon as I
read the pilot I was in I just that and
the fact that Jen and Rhys were part of
this obviously it was really important
but I thought it was great it made it
made sense to me it was it was nuanced
and smart and tragic and imparts funny
but it felt it felt alive it felt very
human to me I thought it was great it is
very unusual for a show to get a one
season pick up let alone a two season
pick up what is it like in the writers
room at the beginning knowing you
actually have this much time to sort of
tell your story it's always it's always
better to know how much time you have
this whole story you're you will
categorically get better stories if you
know what what end you're writing to not
that that's the end but as opposed to
thinking you know well if it ends here
in the first season we don't know if we
have a second season if you know you
have to you can build to the second one
during the first one sure yeah one of
the things I found fascinating is you're
doing a morning show and all of you guys
obviously are passionate about certain
things and one of the things that the
morning show can do is segments on
things you're actually interested in in
real life and sort of shine a light on
that did that actually come up in the
writing process at all things he wanted
to talk about do you mean subjects like
can you give me an example oh so like in
the second episode when Rhys is talking
about how the 1911 fire and say like
those kinds of segments in the show
where the host can actually yes yes it
is actually
great forum for we're talking about a
lot of different things that are
important to to us personally okay
talk a little bit about how much did you
know you you obviously sign on how much
did you know about the full arc of what
your character was gonna be doing and
how much like can you sort of talk about
that like knowing how much do you know
how much is it script by script Carrie
and I got together early on I'd read the
pilot and we met and you laid out the
rest of the season and and we talked
about the characters arc and and where
he was ending up and so that was even
more reason to join because it was it's
it's a it's a really interesting road
that he travels thanks episode I have to
ask one individual another individual
question of you just because I'm I so
love Jon Stewart and he just directed a
film about politics right can you talk
about being getting to work with John on
that film completely different
experience than working with him on the
daily show it I and he he was having so
not that he wasn't having fun on the
daily show but that it was a grind it
was hard all of those you know he was
the show he wrote almost every bit of it
he was in a completely different
creative space and it was a joy we were
in the middle of Georgia shooting that
for a month last year
it was great great fun thank you so much
for your time and cannot wait to finish
the see you Thank You series